hey guys it's justine and today is going
to be a very fun video i'm currently in
hawaii right now with my sister jenna
with a brand new camera this is the sony
a74 and not only am i here for this
camera but we shot an incredible
campaign and i'm so excited to show it
to you guys i'll put a link in the
description where you guys can check it
out but now my friends let's go off on
an adventure
[Music]
i've almost fallen 14 times and we've
only gone 1.43 miles you good yeah
[Music]
what you got look at that we've got a
400 mil gone right now okay this is a
stable environment yeah it's actually
very light good thing i've been working
out
[Music]
it's so
bright out right now we just watched the
sunrise here at kualoa ranch i'm so
excited jen and i are in hawaii we're on
the island of oahu it is one of our
favorite places and for whatever reason
i don't even know how to explain it but
like this place just makes us feel
i don't know energized renewed
everything is beautiful and we've been
coming here for so long there's so many
places that we come that are kind of
like home at this point so we're here
with sony and we're shooting a really
fun campaign for the sony a74 that's
coming out depending upon when you're
watching this it may have already been
announced or released but we're so
excited because this has been our dream
to come here to kualua ranch and film
something we've been here filming before
but we wanted to actually like film
something super cool with the crew and
we have an amazing team helping us film
all of this fun stuff and i can't wait
for you guys to see it it's so bright
the light right now is not the best but
the sunrise this morning was so
beautiful okay we're moving on to our
next destination also i just want to
note that we've been shooting this over
the course of like five days and
we've had to wear the same outfit
how are you enjoying wearing the same
outfit jenna this shirt will be retired
after the shoot and i will never ever
ever wear this color ever again do you
think we'll burn it
no i just donate it that's good look at
this i love this place
[Music]
we're up here a little behind the scenes
setting up for the big camping shop got
a great view but the problem is we have
some rain coming in so we're gonna have
to
figure that out
[Music]
didn't start the fire
we didn't
well like we did it you guys did it
we're supposed to say that we're
starting a fire this is behind the
scenes behind the scenes so we're
starting a fire here um
[Music]
yup
super cozy in the tent
[Music]
so
oh we're action rolling can you put on
two inputs
yep so what was your favorite thing that
we did here that's a really difficult
question i mean i really enjoyed the
dolphins only because that's something
i've never really done or experienced
before i love hiking so obviously
enjoyed the hiking i think my favorite
part which i don't even know if we have
any footage of this is
us trying to put up the tent now in the
edit it's gonna look like we knew
exactly what we're doing but this was
actually the first time i've ever put up
a tent i just realized it have you ever
put up a tent before um like full from
start to finish no not really okay uh no
okay but we got some really cool shots
there i think also my favorite part from
that night was the sporadic rain the
entire crew everybody like we all ended
up just jumping into the tent
it's hiding out 12 to 24 getting used
we were waking up at like 3 a.m to get
like sunrise shoots and the dolphins
though that was also really awesome that
was incredible like the sunrise over the
mountain the clear water the dolphin the
baby there was a baby dolphin it was
like this big it was just the cutest
little thing with his mom and his little
family i guess in the pod also we were
filming with this new camera and we had
access to a ton of lenses normally when
we go out like we've got a bunch of
lenses but since this was a shoot for
sony like we had every single g-master
lens did you get to test out the 400
millimeter on a boat that was an
experience like the lens is not actually
that heavy for what it is but on a boat
trying to get
dolphins from close up i thought they
were going to be far away so we popped
that 400 on and then the dolphins were
like right there in front of us and
jenna has the would you the 16 to 35 35
so that was that was really cool but
yeah watching you with this lens like
the boat going very fast and you trying
to capture the content i was just like
hey if you go overboard i'm gonna i'm
ready to grab your foot so the a74 was
so much fun to shoot with and obviously
we're huge sony fans so to get a chance
to come here and capture some incredible
footage it was such a dream come true it
really was it's honestly everything that
we've always wanted and we got to do it
thank you guys so much for watching
again i will put those links in the
description to check out the amazing
videos that sony created with us and i
cannot wait for you guys to see them we
had so much fun here so thank you again
sony for this awesome opportunity go
check out jenna's video again links in
the description don't forget to
subscribe hit the bell and i will see
you guys in the next video
bye